So in workflows, we were able to say whenever an entry is created or whatever,
we're not doing that here, and that's because
we're manually hitting the submit for approval button.
>> Exactly.
>> Okay. Okay, so select approver using the options below.
Who should this approval request be assigned to? So this again
is something that would be a lot more dynamic if we
had a lot of users in our orginization that had roles.
>> Okay.
>> You could assign it specifically based off of the role
hierarchy in the company. Because maybe you want certain managers to approve it.
>> So that would be the hierarchy field, I assume?
>> Yep. Or you could, you know, choose that
Approver manually. Assign it to a queue. In this
case we're just going to automatically assign it to ourselves
since we're the only user that could approve anyway.
>> So what does that mean. Who should I?
>> Automatically Assign Approvers, and then just choose Yourself.
>> Save?
>> And
Save. So, I just want to call out, that that's really not the
most realistic, as far as, you know, we would always be the approver.
The real dynamic, you know, power behind approval processes, is that you could
get anyone that needs to approve it, based off of their role, or.
>> Their position in the company, yeah.
>> Mm-hm. Alright. So this is explaining how
you're going to build out the approval process. So this
is another one of those setup windows that, if
I weren't here right now, this is how you'd
teach yourself how to do it.
>> Sure.
>> But let's just go to the Approval Process Detail Page.